foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday December 2nd I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
more TV viewers especially younger ones
are using closed captions and not
necessarily because they're hard of
hearing it's just that the audio often
sounds muddled
but shouldn't the audio technology in
our TVs improve how shows sound or at
least let us understand what the actors
are saying joining us to discuss what's
going on here and how you can have a
better TV listening experience is wsj
personal Tech reporting assistant
Cordelia James hi Cordelia thanks for
being here hi Zoe thank you so much for
having me I want to understand what is
happening here I mean a lot of us have
been told that the reason we can't hear
our TVs well is because of the speakers
is it just that simple
it is not actually so even though there
is a good reason why people do say that
it's because of their speakers you know
as TVs have advanced a lot more they've
gotten tinier thinner the speakers are
usually either towards the back or
facing downwards which is directing the
sound anywhere but towards you however
there's actually other reasons from
production issues to just how the sound
will actually be compressed into your
device depending on whatever it is that
you're watching something on okay so
let's talk about some of those issues I
mean when it comes to the technology
that's playing out the sound the
dialogue in your television what's
changed here so the good news is is that
technology that comes with sound mixing
has just gotten so much more advanced so
what sound mixers those that kind of
combine everything that you hear in a
movie TV show the dialogue the music the
sound effects everything they have a lot
more room to play around with combining
all of those sounds however when it
comes to like the more channels you have
the more like the high quality systems
that you're mixing something for that
gets compressed so that way it can also
be played on smaller sets such as like
stereo speakers or mono speakers that's
two or one speakers respectively and so
when you have so much coming out of such
a little bit of sound what you often
have is like overlap which makes things
a lot harder to hear a little bit more
muddled because there's not many places
for that sound to go okay so we we've
got all this sound playing out at once
and I guess we have maybe more sounds in
our TV and movies than we maybe did a
few years ago or you know decades ago
but how are sound Engineers working in
TV approaching this
so the hard part about it is that based
on what I heard from The Sound Engineers
I spoke to is that they don't
necessarily have that much of a creative
say in the way that sound will
ultimately appear in the film or movie
that they're working on that's often up
to the director who will be like oh well
we actually want to make this sound even
Larger than Life so what often happens
is even though sound Engineers were
saying hey like there's all these
explosions happening the dialogue isn't
necessarily at the Forefront of this
director is like hey well if you were an
actual explosion you probably wouldn't
be able to hear the person next to you
anyway I mean it does often feel
difficult when you're watching you know
an action scene to hear what people are
saying in particular but you know we are
trying to to follow the story to hear
what's going on so is there a way that
people can improve their sound if they
want to be listening at home
yeah there are so many different ways or
different things that you can try it
doesn't necessarily guarantee that it'll
sound a lot better number one I guess
the most cheapest option that you can do
is just look at your setup if you have a
TV that has backward facing speakers and
you're hanging up on your wall then of
course that sounds gonna get a little
bit muffled so it might be easier for
you to either set that TV on a surface
that isn't covered by anything that
would absorb the sound immediately like
a wooden TV stand or something as well
as depending on like your room size
there are different ways that you can
try to reorient your furniture maybe
give yourself some carpeted floors or
like some dense curtains that will help
absorb the sound on that wider scale so
it keeps it contained within your room
okay so rearrange the furniture what
else can you do yeah so other things you
can do the most practical way and
sometimes the most expensive is to get a
sound bar the exercise book two I'd
recommend it to at least have three
channels so that way that Center channel
will give you the dialogue and that
helps all the other your distractions
kind of stay off to the side also a
bunch of new TVs have different audio
settings in your TVs menu you can adjust
some of those audio settings doesn't
necessarily guarantee that it'll work
all the time because ultimately what
those TVs are doing are trying to guess
which parts are the speaking Parts
versus which parts are all the other
stuff and if they mix that up then you
might end up still finding yourself
having to readjust the volume every once
in a while I mean what if when I'm
watching TV I can hear it but the people
I'm watching with are having trouble
with some muddled sound yeah fortunately
there are different earbuds that you can
use so for example with air pods you can
link up to two pairs of airpods to your
Apple TV as well as there are some
accessibility features that allow you to
use your phone you put it next to your
TV and then you can put in your earbuds
so that way the phone kind of acts as
this amplifier to help you hear some of
the sound a little bit better Cordelia
while I've got you here I want to ask
about a slightly different but related
Trend you know a lot more young people
particularly people under 40 are using
closed captions not just to Aid in
hearing what's going on in a show can
you tell us a bit more about why this
trend took off yeah so when it comes to
closed captions they're just a lot more
popular now than they were in the past
especially among young viewers often
it's because it allows you to multitask
a lot more so if you're on the move for
example or if you're trying to watch
something in a space where there are
other people you don't necessarily want
to disrupt them or things it's a lot
easier for you to wash them with closed
captions it also just helps you
understand the audio a lot better
especially now that people are getting a
lot more creative with their closed
captions Cordelia James reporting
assistant for the wsjs personal Tech
Team thanks so much for joining us
thanks again and that's it for Tech news
briefing this week our producer is Julie
Chang our executive producer is Chris
sinsley and I'm your host Zoe Thomas
thanks for listening and have a great
weekend
[Music]
[Music]